we're going to have a two-part
presentation today
my colleague lewis will
start us off with giving a
talk about the hug and face hub all the
things you can find on there models data
sets and demos and then i will pick up
from there with how you can actually
build your own demos using the gradio
library it'll be a hands-on demo so
we'll actually jump into some code and
play with it
so we'll do some introductions here
my name is nate i am a self-proclaimed
machine learning hacker
i got my start in data science working
at a at pwc uh as a data scientist where
i built interpretable financial anomaly
detection algorithms for fortune 500
companies
and then i got into open source where i
worked
as a research engineer for pytorch
lightning which is a tool that helps you
scale up your your pytorch
training
and now i work here at hug and face
trying to
democratize machine learning uh lewis
yeah great thanks for having us as well
matt and uh yeah my name is lewis and
i'm also a machine learning engineer at
hugging face i'm a little bit like nate
in the sense that i'm a fake engineer
i'm originally a physicist
and i i did lots of nerdy things around
the large hadron collider concern
um and that was how i kind of discovered
machine learning
through analyzing the kind of petabytes
of data that these experiments produce
and i kind of realized that you know my
future as a physicist was in jeopardy um
from deep learning and that there were
some you know really interesting
problems to to solve in the real world
so to speak
so i switched fields and i've been
working in machine learning for the last
five years or so
and at hugging face i'm the kind of
co-lead of the hugging face course
which is a free course we offer for
people who want to learn about
transformers in nlp and i'm also the
co-author of a recent book by riley
called nlp with transformers
so if you have any questions about
transformers today feel free to put them
in the chat
and as nate was also saying um if you
have any questions about anything we're
talking about just uh just put them in
the chat and then we'll kind of you know
interrupt each other as we go
so
to get started
oops let me see
here we go um i thought it'd be nice to
give a kind of tour um through the
hugging face hub so
if this is the first time you're hearing
about what what is hugging face is it
just an emoji is it a company you know
so forth um the goal here is to kind of
give you a high level picture of what we
do at hacking face and in particular the
kind of
challenges that we're trying to solve in
the space of machine learning and how to
make it more accessible to the broader
community
so
to get started let's like think about a
kind of particular application or use
case
so
a really common task in nlp
is to think about how can we summarize
long documents into
kind of like management summaries so a
very classic thing would be to take for
example news articles and see if you can
find a way to sort of train a model that
can then condense a news report into
something that you know gives you a
quick idea of what's going on and so in
this particular example we might have an
article about a certain uh ceo and you
know he might be tweeting a lot and you
know rigging the stock market
and we might want to be able to sort of
track that kind of in real time because
you know if our business is going to be
impacted we would like to be able to you
know not have to read tons of news
articles to act on that
so this particular task is called text
summarization where we take a long text
and we condense it into a short summary
and the kind of first thing that we
would need to do is really figure out
okay what type of data should we start
with so
what we could do is we could maybe
scrape some news
websites or we may have some in-house
articles that we would have collected um
you know over time from some sources or
our customers
and then we would need to kind of
process and kind of prepare this data
set
ready for you know training an algorithm
or a machine learning model on top of
that
so we've got a data set and then you'd
say okay great now i'm going to
train a model
and you know the whole kind of process
of machine learning is quite iterative
so typically you know you you train a
model you evaluate it um preferably on a
test set that you know doesn't you know
bias the model and the model hasn't seen
and then you would kind of say oh you
know maybe this isn't so great let's you
know iterate again tweak some hyper
parameters and eventually you'll reach
some kind of let's say happy happy path
where you've got a model that you think
is doing quite well
but this whole process is typically you
know kind of time consuming because
every time you iterate you might need to
write a bit of different code you know
tweak these parameters and keeping track
of like you know the process is is often
a bit error prone and you know if you've
ever done lots and lots of experiments
you may have you know shared excel files
with your colleagues or maybe you say
hey i've got a great model here's like
you know the pickled file and i'm gonna
put it in an email and you know this is
like kind of like let's say the the
traditional way that you know a lot of
people you know share
um the sort of results of their
experiments but also you know the
intermediate uh models that they're
training
so this is kind of a time consuming
process typically
and the kind of question that we're
trying to
ask at hugging face is like is there a
better way of
not just training models but sharing
them
and sharing the artifacts that come in a
machine learning
workflow so this isn't just necessarily
a model it may be for example a
processed data set it may also be as i
mentioned before some experimental
results
and the kind of key thing here is to
sort of try to avoid reinventing the
wheel so
um anyone who is kind of familiar with
the ecosystem around ml tooling knows
that there's like tons of you know
different startups uh trying to like
build like you know experiment tracking
or trying to kind of find a way to like
make this whole process um a bit
smoother and the kind of approach that
we take at hugging face is to really
kind of prioritize um a focus on open
source tooling so we try not to you know
integrate too many things that are like
closed source because we feel that open
source is really like the the future of
how we should um develop uh tools and
the other thing that we sort of strongly
believe in is this kind of collaborate
first culture so the idea is that
like most people in machine learning
hopefully aren't just training models in
isolation you typically have some
colleagues whether they're research
colleagues or whether they're just you
know your colleagues at work and we want
to kind of
build the tools that enable you to
collaborate
in the easiest way possible
so
the way that we um kind of think that we
can solve this problem or answer this
question
is by having a kind of central platform
which we call the hugging face hub and
this hub essentially collects
models data sets and as nate will show
you shortly what we call spaces
which are essentially
tools that'll allow you to basically
create machine learning applications in
a really relatively simple way
and the idea is that these kind of three
components are sort of like the central
pieces um involved in taking an idea all
the way through to being able to kind of
demo it and ultimately deploy it
in a kind of production setting
and there are other aspects around the
hub that we won't get into today but for
example we have elements around for
example doing inference and optimized
ways um and if you have questions about
that we can you know take that in the
question answering section
okay so um most people just sort of to
get this out of the out of the way most
people think of hugging face to do with
nlp um and a lot of that is because
transformers
originated from nlp so the very famous
paper attention is all you need was
about machine translation and then this
kind of exploded with things like bert
and gpt2 to cover you know more or less
all of the kind of core tasks in nlp
and since hugging faces built on top of
the transformers library
this is usually the first domain that
people think of
but what we found is that
this kind of general pattern of how do
you easily share models data sets and
demos is kind of like a universal
feature of machine learning and in the
last year or so we've been expanding
into new domains such as speech
vision and more recently reinforcement
learning
and if there's a particular domain that
you're really passionate about for
example maybe it's an aspect of the
natural sciences or maybe it's something
like you know
doing ml for art or someone
you know please reach out to us because
we're really you know interested in
making the the tools as accessible as
possible
so probably by the time that you know we
do this talk again this slide will have
more domains on it but these are kind of
the core ones that we currently focus on
right now
so as i mentioned before transformers is
like the open source library that um
hugging faces kind of builds on
but since then we've kind of expanded
into other aspects of the machine
learning pipeline and so if you do nlp
you know that a really important part is
how do you tokenize your text so how do
you basically convert raw text or
strings into the numerical
inputs for neural networks so we have a
tokenizers library and we also have a
datasets library which we use for
basically sharing and processing data
and we won't go into all these different
components but just to give you a sense
that there are like a broader set of
tools that may be interesting for what
you're doing in your in your work
so the kind of first thing that i want
to show is like you know what does it
mean to have a hub and in particular
what does it mean to have a hub of
models
so here's a screenshot of basically
what it looks like if you go to hf.co
and i think you know screenshots are
great but maybe let's uh do some live
demoing of what we're talking about
so if you go to hf.co
if you have a profile you'll see this
kind of
activity page
but if you're if you if you haven't got
an account you can just sign up and then
you'll see something like this
and if i click on the models page or the
models tab
what you can see is that we've got
something like you know 30 000
different models in the hub
and these models really span
a wide range of different tasks so as i
mentioned before
um it's not just nlp these days we're
now covering um aspects to do with audio
we've got elements of computer vision
and as i mentioned before more recently
with reinforcement learning
so
maybe um is there someone here who has a
particular task they would be interested
in they would like us to like maybe you
know play around with maybe matt or
someone else there's something that you
would like us to play with
somebody speak up or i'll have to say
translation
okay great so translation is um kind of
like a generative task so this is in the
domain of let's say
maybe text to text generation
um and here we've got a a range of
different models so this covers
everything from
summarization
to
also translation and there's um a very
famous set of models which are these
opus
maybe it's in the text generation terms
sorry there are these opus models wait
let's go over here
they're in translation
there we go great
oh is there a translation task
yeah yeah but that's fine okay great
so let me just see this is what happens
when you do live demos make mistakes but
anyway we're going to go with this there
we go there's a translation task
okay good so as i was saying we have
these um
there's a an organization called
helsinki nlp and they have like
literally hundreds of translation models
um basically spanning like you know
different pairs for example english to
german and so on so if we pick on click
on this model
then what you'll see um is typically
what's called a model card
and the model card um what we basically
ask model owners to provide is some like
key information about how the model was
trained
um maybe some information about the kind
of benchmarks and we'll see
in a second when we look at for example
gpt2 that um we also provide lots more
information to do with like the sort of
social impact these models may have
but in any case one thing that you have
on the hub is you basically have a
widget associated with each of these
tasks and this makes it
relatively easy for you to just interact
with the model on the fly so here we've
got my name is sarah and i live in
london and this particular model
hopefully will translate it into german
so if i hit compute
we'll see yeah my name
is london so that looks like a pretty
good
german translation and you could do this
in principle you know for any of these
other different language pairs and it
gives you a sense of like what the model
is capable of and if you happen to be a
native speaker you can also then you
know try more complicated
examples to see kind of qualitatively
how good the translations
so this is just an example of a model
that's hosted on the hub
now if i go back to my slides
um just as sort of summary of what we
have
we've got over these 30 000 different
models there are these at the moment
over 20 different tasks
and the kind of interesting aspect here
from an nlp perspective is that because
all many of these models are contributed
by the community um we actually span a
large range of different languages
and
if you're working in nlp you know that
like one of the kind of common problems
that we face as community is that almost
everything is english-centric
um and you know many of the sort of
best-performing models tend to
unfortunately be in english because
that's where we have most of the sort of
you know say text data and resources
um but many of our community members
have actually contributed really great
pre-trained models um for example in
spanish and in german
um using the the sort of tools in the
ecosystem and then contributing back to
the community so that then other people
in those communities can ultimately use
it for their applications and i
personally find this to be like an
extremely exciting part of how a hub can
enable kind of a global community to
kind of build on top of each other's
work
so
um let's maybe look at a couple of other
features that are associated with um the
hub we've just seen
an example of the model card so if we go
to for example gpt2 this is one that is
like a very famous model that hopefully
doesn't need any introduction
it's the one from openei that kind of at
least for me
made me really pay attention to
transformers
and for example here i can generate text
using this model
and in this model card we've got now
much more information in particular
about the intended uses and limitations
and this is something that again we
encourage our community to really work
hard on because many of these models are
typically biased by the type of data
that they're trained on so in the case
of gpd2
i believe it was trained on reddit
threads and there was some curation
involved but you know reddit has some
nasty areas in it and that those nasty
areas will then be kind of manifest in
the models so if we ask you know a
certain prompt it will typically
generate something that is potentially
racist or sexist
so including information about the sort
of uses of this model is important and
then we also you know ask people to talk
about different aspects of bias and so
you can see here for example
this is a classic case where if you
prompt gpt2 with something like you know
the white man worked as a whatever
then it will provide kind of occupations
that are kind of stereotypically
associated with men so things like bus
conductor plumber journalist and that
kind of like reinforces the sort of
standard problems we have with language
which is that you know things like ceo
are typically associated with men and
you know it kind of precludes the fact
that half population you know is
excluded from that conversation
and then there's other sort of aspects
that you know you can look for yourself
um to do with like the training data and
so on
so that's like a sort of um deep dive
into the model cards
the other thing that's like um
interesting i was mentioning before that
in this process of training models
um
having a way to kind of keep track of
like how your experiments are going is
usually a an important process
and here i've got basically um a sort of
checkpoint from this big science
collaboration which is an attempt to
basically train a very large language
model of the scale of gpt3
and if you look at the model
page you'll see something called
training metrics and here we've
basically integrated
the tensorboard
tool from google
into the hub and this will then show you
for example how things like the loss are
progressing how the batch size is
increasing and so on and this if you're
using the transformers library all of
this will be automatically created for
you when you basically train and then
when you push to the hub
you'll be able to sort of see
you know how your model is progressing
in kind of real time
and so this is this aspect about using
open source tools instead of trying to
reinvent you know our own kind of
experiment tracking tool
just a few more things to um to maybe
showcase here
um
one of the
sort of other important
kind of considerations that is very
topical at the moment is it all about
sort of like
what is the environmental impact of
training large models
and
although places like google and
microsoft kind of offset their emissions
by using renewable energy
that you know isn't necessarily the case
for most of us who are you know using
you know aws or gcp or something and so
if you're interested in tracking
the kind of impact of your models we
also
you can include essentially the carbon
emissions again part of the transformers
library this will be logged during your
training runs
and then just one last thing that is
maybe interesting to mention
again in the direction of evaluation
is that
we store
during training all of the metrics
basically as metadata that you can then
see
visualized on the hub so here is a
particular model a speech model that was
trained or fine-tuned on indonesian
speech files audio files
and here you can see the kind of
reporting of the word error rate and so
on and this allows you to ultimately
then compare different models and see
you know how well they're doing on kind
of very public data sets
um
cool so
one last thing i wanted to mention is
that the sort of machinery behind
everything on the hub is basically git
so if you've never heard of git it's
essentially a way of like versioning
files and keeping track of like the
history and the evolution of how changes
are made to files
and if you click on the files and
versions part
of the hub or of a particular model
you'll see that um you know all these
files are kind of like basically git
tracked files or get history
and you'll see a little lfs
tag associated with some files and
that's called git large file storage so
this is essentially how we manage very
large models you know anything that's
basically over
10
or less say a few hundred megabytes it's
going to be tracked with git lfs and
this means that you can do versioning
using the standard git tooling but you
can handle you know up to terabytes of
data using this
okay so
that's like the sort of let's say high
level of the kind of core features
associated with models on the hanging
face hub um and i kind of emphasized
everything i kind of showed you was kind
of like a transformers model again
because that's most of what um you know
we've worked on
but um in the last year or so nate and
others on the team have been working
really hard to like figure out how can
we integrate other libraries because you
know not everyone in the world is using
transformers and so for example if
you're using care us there's something
called push to hub keras it's like
essentially a function
that then when you train your model
using keras you can also push the
checkpoint or the save file directly to
the hub and then you can load it in your
downstream scripts so the kind of idea
here is what i mentioned earlier that we
try to really be like kind of open
source like first and really kind of
collaborative so that we try to make the
the general tools that we've built
around transformers available to like
you know the wider ml community
so
i've shown you a little bit about you
know models and that's kind of like the
idea is that you sort of pick a
pre-trained model from the hub and then
you train it and then you upload it
um but i haven't really talked much
about data sets which are like a very
important component of the hyundai hub
or in general of any machine learning
workflow
so in the same way that we have
models and a model hub we also have data
sets
and again if i just show you what that
looks like we can see that there's a
data sets tab here
and in this datasets tab we again have a
list of different
tasks
and we have different languages
and different sizes and so for example
if i click on glue this is a very famous
benchmark in nlp
then i'll get some information that is
talking about a particular subset
of this benchmark i can see some
examples and what the labels are and
again we have this concept of dataset
cards so that
dataset owners can then provide
information about what this data set is
about and so on so forth
and what's also like quite cool is that
you can link data sets to models so here
you can see on the right hand side all
the models that have basically been
trained on the
blue benchmark and this allows you to
then ultimately create things like
leaderboards and also visualize you know
which models are doing best on a certain
task and this is something that um i
find personally quite useful because you
know when you're thinking about starting
a project you know especially if you're
doing nlp
most people reach for like bert because
it's like you know in your mind it's the
famous one but since then there's been a
lot of development in you know sort of
like smaller models that achieve very
similar performance things like
distilbert mini lm deberta and so on and
this gives you a way of like kind of you
know inspecting which models
do well on certain
tasks
so
as i mentioned um
like the datasets hub and kind of
strongly connected to that is the the
datasets library
and this um library is a python library
that lets you load any data set from the
hub with a load dataset function
um but the really special features about
it is that it allows you to load larger
than ram data sets um using a technique
called memory mapping so this is a
sort of underlying something called
apache arrow which is a way of basically
instead of loading data directly into
ram you basically have pointers to these
files and then you can basically access
just aspects of those individual files
and so this means that for example you
can
um load in your data set sorry in your
in your laptop um something like i don't
know wikipedia or larger which might be
like you know a gigabyte or more several
gigabytes of ram and you won't block
your cpu
and the other aspect that this memory
mapping provides is you can
process data sets in a multi-processing
fashion um really fast so you can
basically crunch through like you know
20 turrets with 20 gigabytes of data in
about a minute
and we also support things like
streaming so you can basically load data
on on the fly which allows you to then
essentially handle situations where you
may have larger than disk
data sets so
if you're trying to do pre-training
where you may have like a 20 terabyte
corpus something outrageous like this
then that's a bit too big but you know
you get the point um you can actually
process this on the fly um and so you're
only ever loading into
into disk um the the examples that
you're training on and so this can also
be uh quite a useful unblocker for
for ml
so that's uh kind of like a very high
level description of the hub and kind of
like some of the core libraries and now
i'll switch to nate who's going to talk
to us about you know what happens after
we've trained a model so with that i'll
stop sharing and let nate take over
beautiful
awesome thank you oh we got a question
somebody's raising their hand
sure go ahead
yeah
about the data sets um library i don't
understand does it um
fetch the data set from
hacking phase or is it stored virtually
yeah great question so the the datasets
library
lets you download from the hub
any of the data sets that are stored so
for example if i take squad it will
actually download into my hard drive
essentially you know a pointer to this
original file
and then it will convert those files
into this arrow format which means that
you don't have to load the whole data
set into ram
but you can also just in one line
it
heads from
stores locally yeah that's right but you
can also upload local files so for
example imagine that i have my own data
set which isn't on the hub because maybe
it's something private i don't want to
you know share it or whatever then the
datasets library also can load these
files in the same way and it will
also bring you all the kind of features
of you know memory mapping and so forth
okay thank you right and just to add uh
yeah on another point there um
so in some cases it is downloading from
the hub in some cases it's downloading
from the original author's source so it
like it depends on however um
the person who wrote the data set
loading script uh what about it so
there's two types of data sets one is
like the ones that are part of the
library itself that are built in and
then there's community uh uploaded uh
data sets as well so those can either be
coming from the hub downloading from the
hub if they chose to store the data
there or if if
they're using it from the original
author's source it might be downloading
from elsewhere
but yeah
okay um
already moving on
lewis thank you so much lewis covered
you know kind of uh
two of the three biggest kind of pillars
in
machine learning and that's you know
machine learning models and and data
sets and now in this part of the
presentation we're going to be talking
about demos which is what you do once
you've trained your model so you've got
this shiny new model and uh uh what can
we do with it and that the answer that
is demo it
so the goal of this presentation
is to first you know talk about why
machine learning demos are important
and then after that we're going to talk
about um how to build a demo and that's
going to be both
how you may have done it in the past and
and how you can do it with
the gradio library which is what we're
going to be using
and then we're going to get our hands
dirty and actually do some live
programming
with gradio and and hopefully we'll get
to using hugging face spaces so one
thing i actually will share with you
real quickly
is i believe i saved this to my
clipboard already hopefully yes i did
okay i've just sent in the chat the the
link to join the
organization the great the uh the
organization that we created for you you
folks so if we get to the spaces part
we'll be able to all share a space
inside that organization
all right um
so
why demos you know why are demos
important
well you know when a machine learning
model is just stuck as a um
you know a large file that's sitting
inside a repo or if it's something that
you only can interact with via code it's
not very accessible to a wider audience
so what a demo allows you to do is it
allows
your model or or system to be interfaced
with by a wide diverse group of users
and so
you know not only does this help
prove that your results are reproducible
but also allows a diverse group of users
to identify and debug different failure
points or biases with your model which
is really important so it's not just you
know machine learning engineers that are
able to use
your demo now you can now send it to you
know your grandma and your grandma can
use it
uh one question i'd like to ask here is
is anybody here ever built or tried to
build a demo for a machine learning
model
anybody
hit me in the chat i'm getting some nods
yes okay
great uh
and so
uh
you know usually the process of when you
go to build a demo this is kind of this
this uh goes like this right um you know
i really had this i just this awesome
model i trained and now i want to build
a web app
and then you realize
oh crap i have to learn you know flask
docker javascript css all sorts of also
like a whole suite of tools bash you
know and then you kind of give up and
it's a little disheartening right so
the reason for that
is that
there's a ton of different tools that
you have to learn across the the whole
you know life cycle of building a
machine learning app right so you
probably trained your model or built
your model in in tensorflow or pytorch
and then you know if you need to
containerize your your your model you're
gonna have to know bash and docker and
you know to build the app you probably
use flask for the back end and then
you'll use something like html css
javascript for the front end to create
an interactive user interface you might
need something like mysql to handle the
data and then all of a sudden you're
like you know it's been 10 years and now
your model is completely outdated
you went through this whole process of
learning all these these these tools uh
and so that's i mean it takes a long
time to learn these things
so um what gradio does
is it basically takes all those parts
that were um
you know in all these different
languages and makes them all uh
uh accessible via python so now you can
containerize and deploy the model store
data samples build an interactive
front-end interface for your for your
demo all in python uh rape like which is
the language you're used to if you're if
you were using if you're data scientist
probably and you're using
um
you know frameworks like pytorch and
tensorflow
so
now we're going to take a look at a few
example
uh interfaces that were built using the
gradio library
so this one is
jojo gan
it's basically a
face stylization app so you upload sort
of a picture of yourself this is
my colleague omar and this one's going
to try to turn you into a disney
character
so that's that's pretty cool so you can
do things like you know passing images
and get images back
going back to the new summarization
example that lewis talked about earlier
this is a new summarization app so you
kind of give it a
url
to
a
news article it'll you know get the text
from it and it'll try to create a
summary from it
and then this one is a voice
authentication app uh from microsoft uh
where basically you you upload two
different audio clips or record two
different audio clips of uh people
speaking and uh it'll try to tell you if
they're the same same person or if
they're different people maybe just for
authentication for phones or something
you know um and all what all these apps
have in common is that they were they
were built using the the gradio library
and so this is what radio looks like the
idea is that it should be as simple as
possible in just a few lines of python
code you should be able to get up and
running and building interfaces for for
whatever it is you'd like to build an
interface for so um here we see that we
import radio and then we use this thing
called the radio interface class to
define uh what the logic is of your of
your um
interface you know what are you going to
what function are you going to be
interfacing with what the inputs to that
function are and what the outputs are
going to be coming out of that function
and then you just launch the app and
what's awesome about this is that this
could work from uh you know your local
python interpreter this will work from a
jupyter notebook on your computer and
this can work from collab notebooks so
anywhere that you you may be using
python you can build and and use an
interface
so what's also great about this is that
you know uh you know
if you build a demo you know you you'll
have a demo and it works on your
computer cool or you know you have a
demo you have some code for it you can
share it with somebody uh you know on
github and then they have to pull your
code down and run it and then they can
see the app
um
but what people really want to be able
to do is share their their apps for the
community so that anybody can use use
your app
and so that's why
uh we had hugging face created hug and
face spaces
and the idea behind spaces is we want it
to be
we want to make it as easy as possible
to
have folks be able to share machine
learning demo apps with
the community
so on spaces you can basically
take some python code that you wrote for
in either gradient or stream letter or
actually a pure uh static webpage
and you can share that on on spaces and
what we'll do is we'll spin up a virtual
machine and we'll host that for you uh
forever uh for free so uh what's really
great about that then is that you know
as these new models come out or as
people do new and interesting things
with machine learning people build
interfaces around them and then share
them on spaces and then anybody can use
them
and what's great about that is that
it opens up a whole new world of people
that can use your machine learning
models right so uh in this case we're
seeing well you know a few months ago we
released a
um a demo for animegan v2
uh which is again that makes you look
like an anime character and because this
uh because spaces and because gradio
made this so accessible
we found that folks on twitter really
liked it because they'd like to take
pictures of themselves see themselves as
sort of an anime character make it their
profile picture tweet about it etc and
so this is the first time that you know
sort of machine learning models are able
to go uh really viral because uh it will
it accelerates the ability for machine
learning models to go really viral um
which is what's so great about being
able to share things with
community and so you know we're sort of
at this turning point of machine
learning right so before it was just
these machine learning hacker type
people you know uh
that were able to accept to access um
you know state-of-the-art machine
learning but now we're at a point where
anybody with a browser can access these
models and use them and interface with
them and poke and prod these models and
try to identify uh failure points and
biases in these models which which in
turn helps us develop better uh models
right so you know uh because us as
machine learning engineers we might be
biased or we might not understand how to
poke and prod these models maybe your
grandma's the one who's gonna be able to
figure out that it doesn't work when
you're wearing glasses you know or
something like that right uh uh
you never know right so what's great
about this is that you know machine
learning is as accessible as possible
so without further ado what we're going
to do next is we're actually going to do
some live programming
so
here we have a bitly link i will
actually oh i clicked on it i will share
this in the chat as well so you don't
have to
copy it
by hand
and what would be great is if you all
are able to open that notebook
and and follow along with us as we go
here i think that'll really help um
drive home some of these points so i
will kind of walk through it together so
are you folks able to open that notebook
let's open it up
okay wonderful
okay i'm going to jump into that
notebook
and what i'll do is i'm going to scroll
down all the way to this part
um
where we're going to pip install
gradient so pip installing uh so yeah
real quick just to make sure everybody's
on the same page we're in google collab
right now which
if you haven't used it before it's
basically like google docs but for code
so uh here we're able to you know
all work together inside this notebook
that i shared with you you're able to
run the same code that i'm running and
it's all hosted for you by google and so
in order to run a certain cell you can
kind of come in here and you can either
hit command enter or shift enter shift
return whatever it is depends what kind
of computer you're on
i'm not google so we're going to hit run
anyways
and what this will do is this will first
install gradio so the library that we're
going to be using to build
um
demos
so we're just going to give that a
second now at this point does anybody
have any questions and you can go ahead
and feel free to drop them in the chat
or whatever you'd like to do um make
sure i
not breezing too fast here
alrighty
okay so we'll skip ahead um i'm going to
zoom in a little bit just so you can see
that a little better
okay so
basically when you build a radio
interface um
you need to first define the function
that you're going to use to interface
that you're going to build an interface
around so uh what we're going to do here
first is we're going to define a
function called sepia which is going to
take in an image as an array and it's
going to apply a cpf filter on the image
and it's going to do that by calling a
dot product on it with this array here
and so you don't have to worry too much
about uh you know the logic inside this
function just know that
this function takes in an image and it's
going to return an image okay
so we're going to run this cell to make
sure that that function is defined
and then what we're going to do is we're
going to import gradio
and we're going to
create a gradio interface this gr dot
interface
now this interface class takes in three
ingredients
the first ingredient is the function
with which we'd like to interface with
the second ingredient is the inputs so
what kind of inputs are going to be
coming into your function in our case
it's going to be an image so this image
here
is uh the type of variable that's going
to be formatted
and sent to this input parameter here
when we're interfacing with the
function that we created and then we're
going to find the third ingredient which
is the output so the outputs here are
also an image and so in this case it's
going to be expecting
an image type to be coming back so in
this case it's going to be a numpy array
which is an image
and now what we can do is we can run
this cell
and in this cell
once the cell completes uh
running
we're going to see an interface
so here we have an interface um
uh
with which we can upload
an image so i'm going to click here
and
i'm going to use this this meme i was
planning on posting yesterday
uh this is kanye with who loves hogging
face
and we're going to apply a cpa filter on
that and now we see a
kind of comes out at the end
with a filter
so that's great right so what we've done
is we've basically defined an interface
around this function that we we defined
and then we're able to you know kind of
play around with it
okay great any questions at this point
okay
we'll move on to
the the next the next example here
now
this example
uh is going to generate a musical tone
so in this case we're going to to have a
few different inputs so we see that the
function that we're defining this
generate tone function is going to take
in a few different parameters the note
so um you know abcd
on the keyboard
what octave
on the keyboard you would like to
have the note be played at and then the
duration for which you'd like to hear
that note played out and what we're
going to return here is actually an
audio
um we're going to return audio
that is going to represent that note
that octave in that duration
so in this case we've got something a
little bit different right we have three
inputs instead of one so let's see how
we define the the gradient interface for
that
we're going to first right there's three
ingredients so the first ingredient is
that function right the generate tone
function
the second ingredient is
the uh and you don't have to write these
i'm writing them explicitly just for the
sake of demonstration
the second ingredient is the inputs in
this case we see something a little bit
different and that's that there are
three inputs there's a list of inputs
so
this list of inputs corresponds with the
parameters coming into this function
that we're going to be creating an
interface around so the first
item inside this list is going to be a
drop down
type of input so in this case we're
using not the shorthand string
sort of uh uh
definitions like we did earlier where
we're just able to say image
right image here
instead what we're doing is we're
calling to this radio input
these gradio.inputs uh classes and we're
actually defining them directly in this
case we're defining a drop down with
which uh
there's going to be a bunch of the
different musical notes that you can
choose from
these and that will correspond with note
the second input the second item here is
going to be a slider so from four to six
for the octave
and then the third input is going to be
a number which is going to be in the
form of a text box that will just kind
of cast it to an int and that
corresponds with duration here because
one two three right one two three and
when we run this
um
oh i didn't write outputs my bad outputs
that's beauty of uh
live demoing
um
when we run this
we should get an interface that allows
us to create a musical tone so what i'm
going to do now is i'll actually unplug
my headphones and i'm going to
run this
and then we'll see
so i'll choose c
or i'll choose d and then i'll make my
octave six so i'll make it three seconds
and then i'll hit submit
we should get an audio
interface
output back so when i play this
right you should be able to hear that
output and that's pretty that's pretty
cool right so you know we're looking at
you know we're looking at a bunch of
different numpy uh mumbo jumbo here
right and instead of just uh
seeing that and just getting a raise
back now we're able to actually really
easily without having to import all
sorts of other stuff we're able to uh
immediately hear the um the musical tone
that we have here and we're also able to
you know create these dynamic inputs to
write all sorts of multiple inputs you
can also do multiple outputs in some
cases uh we won't be covering that here
but that's also another possibility so
it's really awesome that you're able to
to sort of do this uh as quickly as as
we just did
alrighty any questions about that
all right oh you got a question go ahead
yeah um in
duration time and gets in a
text box
oh wait
i just i was meeting yeah yeah
yeah it takes us text and uh if we we
can type anything we want so it's
uh cause problem because
you know like one because of you doesn't
know
right great great uh great point here so
here's here's how we can solve that
right i'll do this uh live uh we why
don't we do this instead
video.inputs.slider
and we'll do that from uh that's gonna
be a number we'll do it from one to five
or something right and the step is going
to be equal to one um
and we'll get rid of this last one
and uh that should work just fine
um
and so we create that we make that a
slider too i think that's probably a
little bit better of a way to do this so
now we can create that that right and we
can spit and that should work just fine
but yeah that's a great point the text
box leads to potential issues
yes but
that's better i i agree but um
vermi the textbox it says type number
but it still allows to
input
normal text
yeah i'm guessing the issue there is it
probably just needs to have a better
error message because it's going to try
to cast it to an int and then if it's uh
screwing up the uh if it's not it then
it's probably just getting angry it
probably needs to uh it's a great point
maybe we should add like a little bit
better of a warning there yeah
all right another question here
i had a question about um
how much control in the gradio library
do you have over the way in which uh you
know the form the input form is
uh constructed right now i notice
you've just got these objects there and
i'm assuming that gradio just
positions things in some kind of grid or
a window like grid
right briefly what how much control do
you have over
you know the actual construction of that
window
so to speak yeah that's a great that's a
great um uh point so there's uh actually
a uh a couple of options for there's not
it's not too uh you don't have too too
much control you can do things like um
making things uh
uh
horizontal or vertical um
also on a line it looks like there's a
few different options there there's
things you can do with css you can
provide your own custom css to to update
the style so for example like the style
that we're seeing here is a little bit
the style that we're seeing inside the
collab notebook is slightly different
than the style that you might see on
spaces because there's a different theme
so that's all done with css but to
answer your question yeah not you don't
have uh it's not like uh um
something where you're able to kind of
dynamically say i want to have a side
thing here and then something you know
it's not like a layout builder it's more
just the inputs and outputs now in terms
of the inputs and outputs themselves you
can come to radio.app docs which i'll
drop inside the chat and inside there
you can see all the different types of
inputs and outputs that you can have and
also you can read a little bit more
about the
different layout
options that you might have but yeah
that's a that's a good question
that's not a bad thing i'm an old
windows programmer so
if you have too many options and you
can't get anything done you know you
want to get something up so i'm yeah
thank you so much for that that's i
think
it looks like you found a pretty nice
balance here between
you know
being able to demo something and the
right level of functionality to do so
right yeah and
uh when i first found uh radio i've been
a long time user of streamlit and i
remember streamlit being uh you know it
has all sorts of features and that's
great um uh and it's it's great for
certain use cases but when you're just
trying to make a prediction with a
machine learning model you only have
really a couple things that you're
really trying to do you're trying to
define some inputs you're trying to have
a function you're trying to have some
outputs and i think that's where radio
really shines yeah
um okay anybody else before we move on
all righty
okay
so we'll i'm gonna show you something
else that's um
uh pretty sweet so you know lewis talked
about uh the hog face hub earlier how
there's a bunch of models up there so
something that you can actually do
with
with uh
[Music]
with gradio is you can actually call the
gradio.interface.lo so we were using
interface earlier and defining it right
using the init the init method of the
class but instead if we use the the uh
class method load interface dot load we
can load hugging face models directly
from the hub
so how you do that is you know each
model on the hub has sort of an
identifier which would look like this
this facebook fast speech too and uh we
um
pre-penned on this hugging face slash in
front of it to tell it's coming from
hugging face and you're able to
immediately if you run this
load this model from the hub
and so what this is actually doing
is it's going to use the inference api
that that lewis uh
kind of demoed to earlier where he was
writing some things inside the the
widget there and and um uh
making predictions this is actually
going to run right through that but
we're going to have a nice little
interface for it so um
yeah
and if this this will load here
here we go
excellent so this one is
a
text-to-speech model so
um
hey there i am teaching
a class about
machine
i learning how it handles exclamation
marks let's just start yelling who knows
um okay so uh okay this one's spat
something out i'm gonna unplug my
headphones again
hey there i am teaching a class about
machine learning
okay great
great um
awesome so if you know if you're uh
secretly a member of anonymous and
you're trying to
create a new video uh
maybe you could use this text to speech
here uh
all right so let's move on to another
example uh uh
we're gonna take a look at now at uh
luther ai gptj6b so this
this model is a text generation model so
what it does is it takes in some text
and it tries to
auto complete it
and so this is again the the identifier
this luther ai gpt j6b it's actually a
six billion parameter
model which is pretty huge
for being out in the open um
and what we're also going to do is i'm
going to show you that you can provide
examples which will allow you to sort of
prompt users to
as to what they what sorts of things
they can enter um into your into your
interface and what what's really helpful
about this is that you know uh
especially for like image-based apps
when you're building image-based apps
and this really comes into play in
spaces which we'll see in a little bit
uh
folks might come in here and if i ask
one of you right now like what should i
write here you know
you're gonna feel like you're on the
spot right and you're not going to maybe
know exactly what you should put in here
but when you see an example down here
that you can just click and you can try
out
uh
you're immediately like you can
immediately start playing with it and
then you can maybe then maybe that'll
spark creativity for you and you'll know
what you should what you should put so
you know the most moons orbit around
earth has changed many times you know uh
there once was a pineapple
okay
um
uh not sure i like that trend that one's
so much uh well let me go back to this
one uh
and uh yeah so you can write anything
here so um i can say hey
my name is nate and today i am
well let's see
see if we get something good
discussing the game the witcher okay
cool
wonderful
awesome um
so that is uh that is how you'd use the
the interface.load
function
it looks like i got a message in the
chat here the overrides
is
with the most recent
correct yes so i think you're talking
about uh
um let me just clarify so somebody in
the chat said i noticed that it's
overriding the previous public urls with
the most recent model or app and that
was jason now jason can you clarify for
me in the in the um
chat if you're talking about this link
right here yeah yeah so like for example
the one with um
the previous like the sepia filter one
um
when i went to reload that on my phone
it now it's playing the the facebook
speech one
right right so yes i can explain this so
um these public links these public links
are temporary public links so it's where
you can host your app temporarily and
that happens when you use share equals
true in collab it actually happens by
default whether you write shared equals
true or shareable false because uh it
has to do with actually how the
networking works there's no way to you
have to like we're creating a tunnel
basically to the compute um and so in
this case uh this is a tunnel straight
to this compute so whatever app is the
most recent one that's been run is the
one that you're going to be able to find
at this app but what's nice about this
is that i can share this link in the
chat right now for everybody
and you'll be able to open that up and
actually use the same one that i'm
looking at and this is just again a
tunnel a temporary tunnel to this
compute
um
if that makes sense but yeah uh that was
a great great thing to bring up thank
you for bringing that up because i
wanted to talk about that um
and now
because that's temporary you know being
something uh you know being able to
access your app temporarily is nice
because you know while you're developing
maybe you're working with a collaborator
or something you're like hey check this
out real quick you know um but if you're
ready to actually you know if you're
done and you're ready to
um share your your interface with the
world
you need a more
permanent solution
and so as we talked about earlier
that's that's where we um would use
spaces so spaces here
is
on our site so if we go to
hf
hf dot space
um or hf dot co spaces you'll find hug
and face spaces so these are all the
different uh spaces that have been built
some of these you know even as most
recently as four minutes ago people are
building and sharing these spaces
and if you come in here you can hit
create a new space and you can create a
space for yourself it looks like we're
out of time so i won't be able to create
a space here today but what i highly
suggest you do is you come into
uh come come in here create an account
and create a space and so how you do
that you just come in here you hit
create gradient you name it and then you
you'd add an app.pi file which contains
your your
your code so we could even like you know
just copy something straight out this
whole lab notebook and you'll be able to
run these spaces
for free and host them for free
permanently which allows you to share
them with the world and maybe your
machine learning model can go viral
all right
[Music]